نعود لموضوع تحدثنا عنه في الايام الماضيه
عاصفه كليوباترا لم تهدا في مصر في عالم
عالم الاثار المصري الشهير زاهي حواس يرد
عمليا على نتفليكس لن يتركها تمر مرور
الكرام اكيد الرد جاء باطلاق فيلم وثائقي
يروي قصه حياه كليوباترا الحقيقيه كما
وصفها بالضبط وذلك بعدما اثار خيار
نتفليكس اسناد دور الملكه الفرعونيه الى
ممثله سمراء اثار انتقادات واسعه في مصر
خلال الاسابيع الاخيره وثائقي حواس عرض
على يوتيوب تزامنا مع انطلاق عرض فيلم
كيلوباترا المثير للجدل على
نتفليكس يعني بالتزامن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات